let's go next to calvin
from indianapolis calvin welcome
talvin from indianapolis welcome
uh
well david can you hear me yes i can
all right sorry if i didn't come to
claire the first time um i'll keep it
real brief had just a quick gut response
question the second deeper dive question
sure that responds with the washington
post posting uh last night that donald
trump is officially under investigation
do you really think anything is going to
come of that was it really just
investigating his cronies in a circle
around them and second question knowing
how good
the
right seems to be at charging its base
and getting the locals interested in
government seeing since our
basically since
the last politicians
excuse me and democrats have no teeth
when it comes to
getting
anyone on the local level charge
wouldn't you think it might be up to or
good ideas for
platforms
and for lack of a better idea like
you're the young church like hey we're
going to expand out to
local stories or
try different ways to get
different individual states more charged
in your local base such as things that
you're saying hey you could phone lobby
for important races that you brought up
earlier
um for lack of their word like mimidos
that race
i completely agree with you that would
be a great thing to do the difficulty is
for a national show where only you know
i i i my guess would be
no more than one percent of our audience
is actually eligible to vote in any of
like the state
particular state elections right like
how much of our audience votes in
pennsylvania is it one percent i don't
know how much of our audience votes in
you know matt gates district in florida
it's got to be it's a fraction of one
percent so the difficulty is
are we better off
talking about ways for people to get
involved locally so that they do it
wherever is local to them
rather than spending time in one
specific local race that very few of our
viewers might actually even be eligible
to vote in
and possibly alienate people who are
like that's not interesting that has
nothing to do with with my day-to-day so
this is a this is a challenge for
national shows and i don't know what the
answer is but i understand your
motivation for asking about about the
local focus
all right um thanks and once again to
that first
question just to get response do you
really think anything major is going to
affect trump you know the doj saying
something or that really probably this
is cronies i don't want to deflate
anybody but
i still if you just give me an even odds
bet does trump get indicted i still say
no i'm closer to yes than i've ever been
but i'm still on no talvin
yeah yeah yeah
unfortunately i kind of felt the same
way because
the report says
trump is under investigation but it
doesn't specifically say he's indicted
or anything well no but it wouldn't say
that the indictment would come later but
i know what you're saying i'm not
particularly optimistic
all right my friend from indianapolis
thank you so much for the call very very
much appreciate it